Let's write out one way to do it together.
We're definitely going to need an if statement to tell the difference
between whether state is already in chart sub index and whether it's not.
Let me do the hard case first.
I'll check to see if that state is in the list returned by chart bracket index.
If it's not, we have to add it.
One way to add an element to a list is to make a list out of it
and use list concatenation or list append.
Here, whatever chart[index] used to contain, we add that to the list containing just state,
and we store the result.
In this case we return true.
Otherwise it's already there, so I should not do any updates.
I'll just return false immediately.
The key tricks--I have to check to see if state is in chart sub index,
and if it's not, I have to make a bigger list that contains all the old stuff we used to have
plus the new state we're being asked to add.